lost an edge and now does lose it bork strand
trying to feed it to mccan behind the defense
but a good recovery by Fowler minakov brings
it back in drops it off to zis Trevor takes
it in behind the net he scores a lacrosse
goal exactly what Alli Lowe's off asked
for
wow you know the thing about zis when he
does this and executes it is he's moving I
I've seen a lot of guys try it but not while
they're skating at almost full speed what a
Play What a Beautiful play by Trevor zis it's
just amazing amazing hands I think most of the
crowd is just now realizing what he did cuz they
showed the replay a couple of times on the big
board above Center ice and the reaction got a
great deal louder it's his second of the season
how quickly he pulls this off he knows
he's got the speed right to the toe of
the blade and all in one motion
here Puck on the blade wraps it
around and theor not able to hug the post
tight enough here just up top and ziger
again showing that skill look at this MC
delivery super Mo you see all in one MO